here's the question I don't know what's
wrong yeah
is it possible to somehow direct
pollution through our atmosphere and
dispose of it in space all without
harming our atmosphere love your show by
the way oh thank you it depends on what
kind of pollution you're talking about
the stuffs so what you're saying is
rather than pull your rivers or your
ocean yeah you want to pull it the space
in front well since it wouldn't be so
throw it into space you're gonna want to
actually get rid of it you drop it into
a black hole drop it down into the Sun
yeah you want to actually remove the
thing entirely
but what would would it matter to throw
it into space like would that be bad to
say you have to calculate the energy it
takes to throw it into space versa the
energy it takes to completely break it
down in on earth on earth into some non
pollutant right agree and you don't want
to send the whole thing of like sports
into space because that is the way to
dispose of it and I don't know that
sports are destructible at all but so
you'd want to not just scatter it into
space space we might want to travel that
one day so we wouldn't put so much
pollution into space that we'd be like
up and take it to Mars I think they said
that when they had built smokestacks
it's just a little bit of dirty air look
how big the atmosphere is don't worry
about it yeah all right
[Music]